on the season 1 finale of the
mandalorian our reluctant hero and
newest Star Wars icon took enough of a
tumble to necessitate removing his
helmet and giving us a look at his
bloody battered visages why Pedro Pascal
the actor under the helmet looks so
familiar you might have heard about that
plucky little fantasy program Game of
Thrones once or twice in the past but
you may not immediately remember that
Pedro Pascal got his own turn on the
program during its fourth season he held
a recurring role as Prince Oberyn Martel
also known as the Viper an utterly
unflappable duelist slash prisoner from
the nation of Dorne you shouldn't drink
or fight you learn this during your
years in the fighting pits I always
drink before a fight despite appearing
on only seven episodes of Game of
Thrones
Pascal's footprint is still legible on
the series even after it said both were
his characters snappy attitude and his
incredibly gruesome death at the hands
of the mountain during a trial by combat
playing Oberyn earned Pascal sex symbol
status said before becoming the
mandalorian it was his most high-profile
role he was recognized as a standout
performer in what is often regarded as
one of the best overall seasons of Game
of Thrones and his career only began to
sort from there following Game of
Thrones Pascal landed a starring role as
DEA agent Javier Pena for three seasons
on the Netflix historical crime drama
narcos the series charts the history of
the international investigation into an
eventual capture of infamous cartel lord
pablo escobar Pascal consulted with
real-life agent Pena to properly depict
the man's ideological struggle with the
war on drugs futility and the culture of
extreme violence and corruption
perpetrated by both the illegal trade
itself and the law enforcement effort
made to curb it narcos might be more of
a niche selection for the general
Netflix original consuming audience but
the show earned Pascal a large amount of
positive praise the series ended in 2017
after its third season and was spun off
into a Pascal free follow-up series
about the development of the major
Mexican drug cartels entitled narcos
Mexico like every other starving
twenty-something actor living in New
York City in the 1990s and 2000's Pedro
Pascal landed a few one-episode roles on
the various versions of the Law & Order
franchise but you may recognize him from
if you have an Incred
memory another of Pascal's many TV
credits include a brief recurring role
on Graceland USA Network's
law-enforcement drama about undercover
federal agents living out of a
confiscated house in California he
appeared only on the first season as an
FBI agent and the subject of an internal
investigation who comes into violent
conflict with other characters on the
show you may also remember Pascal from
the sixth season of The Mentalist in
which he played another FBI agent Marcus
pike
he looks good friend undercover thing
turning to lesser-known movies Pascal
appeared in the 2018 film prospect which
curiously enough considering his shiny
new job as a Mandalorian is a sight by
Western Pascal portrayed Ezra a
prospector for gems on an alien moon hua
lies with the teenaged main character
see during a test of survival in an
environment that's both ecologically and
socially toxic the movie didn't receive
wide release despite garnering positive
chatter at festivals and being very well
received on Rotten Tomatoes but you can
catch it on Amazon Prime prior to that
role Pascal appeared in the 2015 comedy
horror film blood-sucking Basterds
Pascal stars as the evil sales manager
Mack who was also secretly living as a
vampire to the horrified discovery of
his employees evident Tim this too is a
movie that isn't exactly going to enter
into the annals of cinematic history but
office space plus vampires equals
wholesome b-movie horror schlock the
last few years have seen Pascal land
rolls and higher profile movies
including the equalizer 2 and a feel
street could talk being a part of the
Star Wars universe doesn't quite count
as existing within the superhero genre
but no worry
like most relatively high profile actors
today Pedro Pascal's got a couple of
Cape films under his belt in 2017 Pascal
played the American cowboy spy operative
agent whiskey and Kingsman the Golden
Circle the sequel to the 2014 original
that's based on the comic book series
Kingsman reviews for the Golden Circle
were middling at best but just like its
first iteration Kingsman Secret Service
the flick is chock-full of gratuitous
slo-mo and cartoonish violence but this
time Pedro Pascal is there sporting a
Stetson pascal's next comic book movie
role is yet to come
Pascal will be joining the DC Cinematic
Universe in June 2020
it's one of the antagonists of Wonder
Woman 1984 Maxwell Lord
he's a peak 80s greed is good kind of
villain and apparently has magic
crystals that grant wishes we still
aren't sure what Maxwell Lords end goal
is as a super villain but we can't tell
you how excited we are to see Pascal
choose some scenery check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stars
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]